descubre su aula está a punto de entrar
en su primer año en la escuela primaria
número 17 de irpin
me gusta mucho esta clase quiero empezar
a estudiar cuanto antes con mi profesor
la escuela estuvo cerrada durante varios
meses debido a la guerra pero las clases
continuaron en línea
ahora los profesores están encantados de
volver a trabajar frente a frente
la enseñanza es mi pasión es el trabajo
de mi vida me encanta trabajar con niños
y los he echado de menos la educación en
línea Simplemente no es lo mismo y para
los niños ni para mí no hay contacto
rodislab pudo ver su aula porque su
madre da clases en esta escuela mientras
los obreros se apresuran a terminar el
edificio antes del comienzo del curso
escolar Natalia llegó para ver su aula
solo 11 alumnos de 32 asistirán
físicamente
me preocupan los niños que estarán en
clase conmigo y tener que combinar la
enseñanza de niña con la presencial
Espero que no haya demasiadas sirenas
antiáreas que todo está en calma
[Música]
las escuelas ucranianas solamente pueden
abrir si tienen un refugio antibombas
funcional aquí la administración decidió
aumentar su capacidad con estos bloques
de concreto aún así solo se permitirá la
asistencia de 300 estudiantes de los
2000 que venían habitualmente